[Musique]
1914 1918 il ya cent ans la première
guerre mondiale prenait fin et il y a
dix ans le dernier poilu lazare
ponticelli mouret il avait participé à
la bataille la plus symbolique de cette
guerre gardin quand mary beaucoup de
morts au cours de cette table de verdun
c'est l'une des batailles les plus
sanglantes de la première guerre
mondiale
cent soixante deux mille soldats
français et 143 milles soldats allemands
ils laisseront leur vie témoignage d'un
survivant en 1991 en octobre le groupe
ne savais pas que nous aller pour un
commandeur j'ai pu travailler leurs
premiers mots c'était beau les soldats
français venaient de toute la france
mais aussi des colonies près de trois
quarts de l'armée française sont passés
à verdun les journées de ces poilus son
rythme et entre l'attend le bruit la
boule époux mais surtout les obus 23
millions d'obus tirés côté français 30
millions côté allemand et ceux qui ne
mourrai pas été souvent amputer
intoxiqué défigurés et brûlés en tout
plus de 400 mille blessés pour les deux
fronts je veux que les balles le rap et
auteur de mon casque n'est pas et je à
ce moment là non je n'ai pas peur j'ai
vu chèques non je le lave ou comme ça je
pensais tout simplement faux chicha pas
discuter mais c'est comme ça et je me
suis dit bien autrement mon chavatte
percale cannes et le moment où tu
m'auras et quelque chose
les soins apportés à ces blessés étaient
sommaires en 24 heures deux médecins
pouvaient prendre en charge jusqu'à 4000
hommes et leur consacrer en moyenne 15
secondes c'est parce que l'hôpital
ce clivage presque à l'hôpital j'avais
parce qu'il coupait les jambes et les
mois il y avait
et du monde qui attendaient dehors des
brancards des blessés couchés par terre
il y en avait partout pensée allemand il
y avait de tout et plus est en même
temps surpris par les gaz verdun 300
jours une boucherie neuf villages ont
été rayés de la carte
six n'ont jamais été reconstruit et sont
déclarés village morts pour la france
[Musique]